[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre
aujourd'hui comme hier ceux qui sont en
première ligne comme l'a dit notre
président gérard larcher
ceux qui doivent organiser les
solidarités d'urgence ceux qui ont la
charge d'annoncer les morts mais aussi
de réparer les vivants ce sont les
maires et cette réalité cette réalité
civique française rend encore plus
insupportable opération de dénigrement
balances ton maire je sais certains dans
votre majorité
bien heureusement s'en sont distingués
malheureusement aussi votre gouvernement
ya prêté la main parce que c'est lui qui
a le premier donné le signal de la curée
monsieur le président au caillou quand
j'ai pris des décisions impopulaires je
les assume et les maires quand ils
doivent prendre des décisions
impopulaires il les assume également
dire qu'un certain nombre de maires ont
augmenté la fiscalité ça n'est
absolument pas mettre en cause leur
personne ce n'est absolument pas mettre
en cause leur mandat
ça n'est absolument pas cela et je suis
surpris des réactions et la vivacité des
réactions au moment où je m'exprime
assumer des décisions y compris quand
elles sont impopulaires
c'est souvent la responsabilité et c'est
souvent l'honneur des élus je le fais
pour ma part systématiquement et
j'indique avec clarté en toute
transparence
quelles sont nos positions oui c'est
vrai il est vrai que un certain nombre
de conseils municipaux ont décidé
d'augmenter la taxe d'habitation c'est
un fait il est public
il est public chacun chacun le sait
chacun peut le savoir il suffit de lire
sa feuille d'impôts pour le constater
c'est une donnée publique et vous le
savez parfaitement je ne m'associerai
jamais à une quelconque opération de
délation ou de critique mais dire de
façon la plus explicite possible
qu'alors que nous avons choisi de
procéder par dégrèvement s'agissant de
la taxe d'habitation à la demande
d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre d'élus et
un demande d'un certain nombre de
sénateurs un certain nombre de maires
ont décidé d'augmenter la taxe
d'habitation
c'est leur liberté c'est leur
responsabilité le pointer ce n'est pas
les pointer du doigt c'est faire état
d'un fait
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
reçu tous les parlementaires de
seine-saint-denis le 26 septembre
dernier et tous vous ont dit avec
responsabilité
la même chose de droite comme de gauche
tous vous ont décrit la même situation
monsieur le premier ministre vous nous
avez écouté réclamer l'égalité
républicaine
nous attendons des mesures fortes en
matière d'éducation de police de justice
ils nous font sur ces sujets ne laisser
aucun répit et immédiatement des jeunes
ont été interpellés trois ont été
interpellés deux sont placés sous écrou
et il est évident qu'il faut que la
justice fasse son travail et enfin c'est
garantir la sécurité de quotidiens sur
la voie publique et c'est pour cela
monsieur le sénateur qu'après la
suppression de 12 mille policiers et
gendarmes en france après le
démantèlement de nos services
d'information nous nous sommes engagés
le gouvernement de la mandature
précédente et ce gouvernement actuel a
recruté dix mille policiers
supplémentaires qui m'ont été demandé ce
matin par les élus rené merci
[Musique]